now you all know we've been covering the
homelessness crisis in California for
months and yet nothing seems to be
improving despite all the money being
thrown at the problem and I'll tell you
what's happening the state leadership is
failing the people but Californians well
I got to tell you there is hope on the
horizon because the Trump administration
is preparing a sweeping plan to get the
homeless off the streets of Los Angeles
and other cities it's all part of the
president's push to renew urban America
it's music to our ears
and even places by the way that didn't
vote for him he's the president of all
the people right here with me now for
more on this and some other interesting
stuff that was happening at the White
House got no coverage ben Carson
Secretary of the Housing and Urban
Development
dr. Carson what can you tell us about
what the president's passion here is and
what is his ultimate goal well we've had
multiple conversations about the
homelessness situation which seems to be
worse in places where there's a lot of
regulatory barriers and California is a
poster child for that and if you go out
there and you see some of those people
on the street and you talk to them you
know many of them simply are not capable
of taking care of themselves and you
know we have to take some responsibility
here now generally it's the
responsibility of the locality of the
city of the municipality to take care of
people but if that's not happening you
know it evolves to a another level so if
the city and the state are not taking
care of it the federal government is
obviously going to do something and the
president is very passionate about doing
something about even in places where
they don't support him didn't vote for
him probably won't vote from him that's
kind of the firing yeah it doesn't care
about that he looks at these people and
recognizes that they're human beings and
we have a responsibility to take care of
them
now you know that doesn't mean that we
won't work with the localities and you
know I don't want to say specifically
what's going to be done cuz I don't want
to get out ahead of it but obviously we
can't just leave people in those
situations well
Eric Garcetti the Democrat he welcomed a
federal delegation we were just learning
about this in the Wall Street Journal a
federal delegation my earring just fell
off kind of live TV so I'll just put it
back while I'm talking this is what we
women do so a federal delegation was
there and he said that he welcomes the
opportunity to work with the
administration he was kinda puts a lot
of money right yeah so that's the catch
I mean they they already planning 1.75
billion dollars in their budget and June
and they want some help I would imagine
from the federal government but are you
gonna keep advocating that we pour money
into California without real changes to
how they deal with the homeless of
course that's the definition of
craziness doing the same thing over and
over again and expecting a different
result it's going to be the same result
what we really have to do is get to the
root cause of the homelessness situation
and deal with it and as I've said before
you know Tokyo which has more plate more
people than New York City has no
homelessness now you know one of the
left-wing organizations came out that
Carson says there's no homelessness but
there's AK C 0.01 9% they found the two
people who were homeless but you know we
actually have to be serious about
dealing with these problems and it can
be done it's a matter of taking
advantage of the tremendous technology
we have removing the barriers right now
they can't clear people out unless they
have a place to put them that's one of
the regulatory burdens there's a lot
more that we don't know enough time to
get into tonight I want to talk about
what happened today at the White House
this is really exciting because we have
the president coming forward again
getting very little coverage in the
mainstream media on the historically
black colleges and universities and the
faith-based ban on any federal funding
what did he do
well you know one of the first executive
orders that he signed was transferring
the council on HBCUs back to the White
House just show you the priority that's
been put on it he's asked all the
different agencies to do what they can
to help with the with the universities
and you know there
probably five or six hundred people
they're in there now do you think you
will hear that story on there were a lot
of news outlets it you think you'll hear
a story of course not now Hollywood
celebrities will say he doesn't care
about black people I mean this is the
constant refrain and they're saying it
secretary Carson I think they're really
afraid of the needle moving even a
little bit in trumps direction in 2020
he's not doing this because of that
because he was doing stuff that was
really positive and great results for
the african-american community even
before this but this is just one more
measurement of his commitment well I
think people will begin to recognize
what's going on you know this is not
about Democrats or Republicans it's
about people who are American citizens
and the fact that the rising tide lifts
all boats and this is this is the way
that it's thought about and that's why
it's working
lowest unemployment ever for black
Americans it came down even lower in the
last analysis are you having fun all
things considered would you rather be
doing brain surgery I mean honestly it's
easier than what you're doing here right
probably dealing with more reasonable
people thank you thank you so much